[Music]
we have explored the method of string
compression called burrows wheeler
transform that's going to let us convert
the repeats of a genome into runs
so that we can apply some other
compression such as run length encoding
there is a strange observation in
burrows wheeler transform
for example if we consider the string
panama bananas
you will notice that if we start with
the last column we get the first column
for free
for example the six occurrences of as is
highlighted here
in the first column the six occurrences
of this also appear in the last column
if we look at the first a in the first
column and the first day in the last
column
you'll notice that these two was
correspond to the same position in the
string panama bananas which is the third
a in panama bananas
you can see that this pattern is
consistent throughout
we can look at the ends too it's not
something that's particular to a
it's for any symbol so if we look at the
ends
the first appearance of and in the last
column and the first appearance of end
in the first column
they both correspond to the highlighted
ends here
we will try to verify whether this
property of burrows wheeler transform
hold in general
if we look at the six columns that start
with an a and they're sorted
if we chop off an a the rows are still
sorted
this is because they all start with a
and the remainder of the strings are
still sorted
now if we add this a back to the end
then those strings should still be
sorted because all we did was add an a
to the end of all of them
so we've essentially done a cyclic
rotation of our six original strings
where we just took the a
and put it on the end and those strings
remain sorted
so what that means is if we look for
those cyclic rotations back in the
original burrows wheeler matrix wherever
they are
they should still maintain the same
ordering
short this is known as the first last
property where the k
occurrence of any symbol in the first
column and the k occurrence of any
symbol in the final column of the
burrows wheeler matrix correspond to the
exact same position of that symbol in
the original genome so you can index
your occurrences of each symbol in the
first and last column
for example the index of the sixth a
here in the first column is
corresponding to the sixth a here in the
last column
same for the ends index n1
and 2 and n3 in the first column here
correspond to n1
and 2 and n3 in the last column here
how does this relate to pattern matching
here is an example
presumably we want to match the string a
a to the genome string panama bananas
we start from the last character a we
look in the first column
and we can identify on the rows that a
appear
then the next character n we will look
at the last column
and our search now limit to the string
with n1 and 2 and in three
using the first last property we can
also identify where
n1 and 2 and 3 appears in the first
column
so now we have identified two letters
the next is a we just go back and find
all a
using the first last property and we can
again know where the a3
a4 a5 appear in the first column
in this case the string a a appears
three times
in the genome string in the previous
example
we show that we can identify which
pattern matched to the genome using
burrows wheeler transform
however for multiple pattern matching
problem we also need to find where is
the pattern matches happened
so the question is can we use burrows
wheeler transform to reveal these
positions
if we go back to our example we know
that a a occurs three times in our
genome panama bananas
if we're using burrows wheeler we only
have the first and the last column
and we don't know where it is that these
pattern matches are occurring
so we'll use a data selector called a
suffix array to do this
we are going to identify the starting
position of each suffix at the beginning
of a row
each row of the burrows wheeler
transform corresponds to a cyclic
rotation of our original string
so if it's a cyclic rotation then we can
walk to some point and reach the dollar
and that walking corresponds to a suffix
for example the first row is just the
dollar sign
so it is the suffix at the end of the
string and that's in position 13
so we put a 13 on that row the next rows
begins with a bananas and the a bananas
is in position 5 of the original string
so we put a 5 in the second element of
the suffix array
if we go through this we will be able to
construct an entire suffix array
how is that helpful to find the matches
well
if we look at the three occurrences a
and a that we found we can identify the
corresponding elements in the suffix
array
it tells us that a a occurs at positions
1 7
and 9 of panama bananas